them receive citations. And the biggest mistake
that holds them back is that they blindly follow
the rulebooks of academic writing style.
But the real tragedy is not that they don’t
get citations; it’s that their research doesn’t
impact all the lives that it was destined to.
Imagine if Watson & Crick’s discovery of the
structure of DNA had never been published;
there would be less understanding of genetic
disease, no CRISPR, and no personalized medicine.
Fortunately, Watson and Crick were good
writers, and their use of academic style
is one of the reasons why their discovery had
such a great impact on the scientific community.
So today we’re going to follow in their
footsteps by looking at three tips for academic
writing style that have been scientifically
proven to increase the likelihood that your
research will get published in high impact
journals and cited by others in your field.
Welcome back to Writer Science, the channel
where we explore the art and science of
professional and academic writing.If you’re
new here, my name is William and I’m an English
professor based in South Korea, and for the
writing tips in this video come from an analysis
of over 30,000 articles with high impact ratings
– that is, those published in top journals or
which received a ton of citations. And the results
might surprise you – they certainly surprised me.
Now of course, scientific ideas spread because
they are valuable. But let me ask you this:
If a tree falls in the forest and
nobody hears it, does it make a sound?
And if you make a discovery and nobody
reads about it, does it make an impact?
The main reason why so many academic researchers
don’t get the attention they deserve is not
because their work isn’t valuable; it’s
because of the biggest mistake going:
they just blindly follow the academic writing
rulebooks and never learn how to use academic
writing style effectively, and for that
reason their ideas are dead in the water.
Luckily, the first common mistake
to avoid is pretty straightforward:
In the propagation of ideas, it’s
essential to prioritize the cognitive
accessibility of the discourse over the
display of the originator's erudition.
Got it? Good. Moving on. The second mistake is…
According to the rule books, academic writing
is supposed to be complex. If it’s too simple,
they say, then it will make the ideas
seem simple and unimportant, and they’ll
never get published in high-impact journals.
And it’s actually true that the complexity of
your writing has a big effect on whether the
research will be accepted for publication,
except that it’s in exactly
the opposite direction.
This study by Oppenheimer took a group of
original essays, and then kept the ideas
the same but increased the complexity of
the language. If the rule books are right,
then you would expect that the more complex
articles would have higher acceptance rates
than the simpler originals. But exactly
the opposite is true. The essays with the
highest complexity were rated worse than
the moderately complex ones, which in turn
were rated worse than the simple originals.
And this is true across genres. From college
admissions essays to research reports, simpler
language leads to higher acceptance rates.
And to show you why that is, I need
you to consider the way ideas spread.
If an idea is carried by complex language,
then it will never make it off the page
and into the mind of the reader. That’s
because there’s only so much work that
a reader is willing to do to unpack
your writing and find your message.
On the other hand, when an idea is presented
in clear language, it can move easily from
the page to the mind of our reader. And
when the reader can grasp our idea easily,
they’ll be more likely to carry it and pass
it on to others in the form of citation.
Many academic writers like to dress up their ideas
in complex language in order to make themselves
appear smart, but this just turns off the reader.
So the goal of our writing should not be to make
ourselves seem smart; instead, we should write
in a way that makes the reader feel smart.
Now one thing I have to make clear here
is that we’re not talking about dumbing
down our ideas. We don’t want to talk to
the reader like a fifth grader. What we’re
talking about is packaging our ideas in a way
that will be easier for the reader to process.
But how do we reduce complexity?
This is our idea; and this is the
DNA of the idea. Except we don't
call it DNA; we call it Syntax.
Syntax is like the DNA of an idea because
it’s code we use to share and replicate
ideas. If the code is complex, then
there are going to be mutations in
the DNA and the idea won’t make
it into the mind of the reader.
So we need to make sure the code is as
simple and straightforward as possible.
Here's the same idea presented
in two different codes.
Which one is easier to understand?
It's the second one, of course, because in
the DNA of ideas, there are only two elements:
content words (like nouns, verbs, and adjectives);
and function words (like
prepositions and determiners).
Each of these codes use the same content words;
but one uses way more function words than the
other. When a sentence has a lot of these function
words, it becomes heavy with all these branches.
Academic articles written with fewer articles
and fewer prepositions in the
introduction get more citations.
The fewer function words, the simpler the
sentence; and the simpler the sentence,
the easier it is for the reader to get our idea
and the more likely they will be to share that
idea with others, which brings us to the
second rule about academic writing style.
According to the rule books, academic writing
should be formal and impersonal. After all,
we’re not talking about literature here;
this is science, and science is objective.
This objectivity, according to the rule book,
should be reflected in the writing style
itself. It doesn’t matter who does the research;
what matters is the research itself.
That’s why so many academic writers
choose to use passive sentences and avoid
the use of personal pronouns. Pssst... and
it’s also why their research fails to
pick up publications and citations.
To understand why impersonal language doesn’t
work in academic writing, take a look at this:
It's a Klein bottle, and it represents a
mathematical surface that has no edges or
orientation - no outside, and no
inside. It can be thought of as a
higher-dimension analogue to the Mobius
strip, but, unlike the Mobius strip,
which has only one side and one boundary,
the Klein bottle has no boundaries at all.
Now compare that description of the Klein
bottle with this one, from a popular TED talk.
Which presentation are you
more likely to remember?
The information is the same, but when it’s
presented by a researcher who is clearly
passionate about the Klein bottle, it’s a
lot easier for us to share that interest.
People relate to other people, and
readers are people, so when there’s
a person present in the story, it makes
it a lot easier for the reader to connect
to the story and receive the ideas.
And that connection makes it a lot
easier for the writer to persuade the
reader that the research is valuable.
Now it’s important to note that this doesn't work
in every place throughout the entire article.
Personal language only helps
with citations when they’re in
the front matter, which is the
introduction and the abstract.
By contrast, articles that use personal
language in the middle section–the methods
and results–actually receive fewer citations.
And to understand why that is, we need to
consider the purpose of these sections.
The purpose of the mid section is to unpack
the finer details of the experiment itself.
It’s sometimes known as the empirical section.
At this point of the report, the reader
doesn’t care about the story; instead,
readers come to this section to examine
the author’s methods and findings.
So it makes sense that the most successful authors
would use passive and impersonal sentences,
which hides the presence of the
author and highlight the work itself.
On the other hand, the purpose of
the front matter–the abstract and
introduction–is to motivate our reader,
to get them interested in our research.
If we introduce this research using
impersonal language, then it’s like the
Klein bottle; the reader’s not going to care.
But like the mad scientist in the TED Talk,
the most successful articles use personal
language in the abstract and introduction
in order to capture the reader’s interest and
motivate them to read the rest of the report.
But not only can personal language
help capture the reader’s interest,
it also changes the way the reader perceives you.
When you take personal ownership of ideas,
it makes you seem more authoritative. If you
introduce valuable research with personal
language, readers will associate that value with
you, making you seem more credible and important.
So if your work is any good, then don’t be
shy; let the reader know that it’s yours,
especially in the front matter.
If you follow the lousy rule books
and stick with impersonal language, your
research will appear lifeless and detached,
as though the ideas–your ideas–are
just out there floating in the ether.
But to understand the third and final tip
about academic writing style, I want you
to take a look at these two restaurant
reviews. Which one seems more appetizing?
Many people would agree that the one written
in the present tense sounds more convincing.
But if the present tense is more convincing,
then why do so many academic rule books tell us
to write about research using the past tense?
A lot of people think that they have to use
the past tense to talk about research in the
past. Makes sense, right? It's the past tense;
research happened in the past. But that's wrong.
It's kind of a deeper grammatical point that
we don't have to get into here, but the basic
message is that tense has nothing to do with
time, and there's no rule that says you have
to use the past tense to talk about research
just because it happened in the past. In fact,
there are some really good reasons to use
the present tense whenever you talk about
your own research. When we divorce tense
from time, it becomes really easy to see
why authors who write about their research
in the present tense receive more citations.
Just like the restaurant reviews, the present
tense makes research seem more current, relevant,
and applicable. The past tense, sounds like
old news; it's passé, stale, and forgotten.
So when writing about your own research,
using the present tense will make it seem
more current, more alive, which makes it
more likely to get picked up for citation.
Yes, the research happened in the past; but if we
follow the rulebooks and write about our research
using the so-called past tense, then
it’s going to seem like old news,
so breath life into your research
by using the present tense.
So I really hope you see that, if your research
isn't getting the attention it deserves,
it’s really not your fault; it’s the
fault of the old academic rule books.
But to tell you the truth, if it's
citations that you’re looking for,
you would actually be better off not writing
a research report at all and instead,
you need to check out this video right here
because it’s going to show you how to write
a different kind of academic article that has
been shown to get cited way more often and over
longer periods of time than the standard IMRaD
research report, so be sure to go check it out.